horas antes de que oficialmente inicie
la campaña electoral para el 23 de Julio
en España los políticos ya tienen actos
públicos organizados el partido
socialista inició en Madrid en este
Pabellón de convenciones de la casa de
campo donde el presidente del gobierno
Pedro Sánchez muy enérgicamente pidió la
confianza de los votantes para avanzar
cuatro años más en un momento en el que
dice el debate público ha retrocedido 20
años esto en alusión a los pactos entre
partido popular y vox de ultraderecha
tras los comicios municipales y
regionales de mayor que han venido con
polémicas como La retirada de la bandera
lgbt o la cancelación de algunas
representaciones culturales en alcaldías
gobernadas por esta coalición por su
parte el líder de la oposición y
presidente del partido popular feijó
quiso empezar en su pueblo natal una
zona rural del noroeste de España ahí
volvió a hablar de derogar El sanchismo
mientras abogaba por recuperar la
cordialidad los acuerdos y el consenso
Pese a que el partido popular no ha
apoyado ninguna reforma de las llevadas
al parlamento por el gobierno el lunes
será el el único debate cara a cara de
estas dos semanas entre los candidatos
de los dos partidos más votados en
España una campaña atípica con menos
mítines y más apariciones en
televisiones redes sociales para llegar
No a sus votantes sino a los indecisos
que rondan el 15%. las encuestas por
Ahora siguen dando ventaja a la derecha
del partido popular que tendría que
pactar con la ultraderecha para poder
gobernar el partido socialista estaría a
seis puntos porcentuales por detrás del
partido popular pero en ascenso y sumar
la cuarta fuerza política liderada por
la vicepresidenta segunda Yolanda Díaz
recién formado este bloque de izquierdas
sería la cuarta potencia política y
también sería clave para poder formar un
bloque de izquierdas que pudiese
gobernar con el apoyo de otros grupos
políticos más pequeños